revenu je pense que la loi française est
suffisamment bien fait pour protéger les
enfants pour qu on puisse également
l'appliquer à ses enfants sur internet
et pour répondre à ces attaques ce sont
les enfants eux mêmes qui prennent la
défense de leurs parents en ce moment il
ya des vidéos critiques sur youtube qui
parle de moi ils disent que je vais
exploiter dans ma mère se fait du fric
sur mon dos je me suis vengé sur youtube
pour m'éclater
c'est n'importe quoi contrairement aux
vidéos de ces jeunes youtuber ce
reportage n'a pas passionné les foules
seulement 1 million 600 mille vue je
crois que les vidéos de d'enfants
youtube hearts et c'est un carton absolu
il y en a certains qui font dix quinze
points de vue sur des joues et vous ça
vous choque 1er mai alors ça me choque
parce que nous avons parce que quand on
filme un accouchement c'est joli je
trouve qu'à une histoire c'est pas
pareil là s'est professionnalisé un
enfant s'est passé c'est pas la même
chose
moi y aller il ya des tas d'adolescents
qui me contacte tous les jours mais tous
les jours pour être instagram heures
pour être rémunéré je refuse
systématiquement parce que je trouve
qu'à 16 ans tu vas à l'école tu es tu
dis tu te concentres sur tes devoirs et
après on en parle parce que il ya des
gens aujourd'hui qu'ils sont sains en
télé réalité qui n'ont pas eu la
possibilité après de faire des études
mais à 16 ans tu fais tout ce qu'il faut
pour faire telle est la loi
l'argent est ce que ça va alors vraiment
et vous avez bloqué pour les enfants qui
seraient bloqués ou alors normal comme
ils l'expliquent dans le reportage
il y à un vide juridique autour de ces
enfants youtuber c'est que ça relève
plus non pas d'une activité ludique mais
d'un travail illicite a pressé les
parents naturellement qu'ils récupèrent
une ce cas leur majorité
c'est ça le problème justement ce cas
pas d'encadrement légal théoriquement
effectivement lorsqu'un enfant travaille
son argent est bloqué jusqu'à sa
majorité
et là sont les parents qui ont des
boîtes de production qui prennent les
revenus et qui font croire que les
enfants ne travaillent pas alors que
rien quand même un des parents qui a dit
qu'il avait produit 1500 vidéo en car et
c'est vraiment du travail dissimulé
c'est voir une saveur de rongeurs est
importante